تقف النساء في جميع أنحاء العالم في
الواقع يرقصن تضامنًا مع
رئيس وزراء فنلندا ، مئات
مقاطع الفيديو التي ينشرن فيها أنفسهن يرقصن
لدعم رئيس الوزراء سانتا مارين التي
تعرضت للنيران بعد ظهور مقطعين فيديو
لحفلتها مع صديقاتها من قناة سي إن إن
ميليسا بيل تعيش في باريس الآن ميليسا
أنا.  لن يطلب منك الرقص أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل ، ولكن من فضلك قم
بتفصيلها من أجلنا ، آه لماذا
يرقص الناس ومن الواضح أن هذا يبدو أنه يقضي
وقتًا ممتعًا ، لكنه أصبح
جدلًا كبيرًا
جدًا ، لقد أصبح جدلًا كبيرًا
بمجرد هؤلاء  ظهرت مقاطع فيديو الأسبوع الماضي كما
قلت عمر ، كانت هذه مقاطع فيديو خاصة
. ندم رئيس الوزراء الفنلندي في
البداية على أنه تم تسريبها على الإطلاق
أه لم يحدث أي شيء غير مرغوب فيه ، لم تقل
شيئًا غير قانوني بالتأكيد تحت
الضغط رغم أنها
أجرت اختبار المخدرات يوم الجمعة من منتقديها  لإثبات أن
ما تقوله هو حقيقة أنها
لم تتعاطى المخدرات أبدًا في حياتها بما
في ذلك سنوات مراهقتها التي تعترف بها
بالطبع كان الرقص صاخبًا ،
لكن تقول إنه من المهم أن
تكون قادرة على القيام بالأشياء العادية التي كانت
تبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا في إجازتها ،
لم يكن لديها اجتماعات مهمة في ذلك الأسبوع ، ولم
يتم ترك أي مسؤوليات حكومية
جانبًا لكنها جاءت  بسبب هذا
النقد العنيف ، من هنا جاء رد الفعل العنيف
الذي رأيته عندما تقول إن النساء
ينشرن صورًا لأنفسهن يرقصن
أحيانًا يسربنهن بشكل صاخب
لأنهن
يضعنهن في المنشور مع علامة التجزئة التضامنية مع سناء
لإظهار أنه يمكنك أن تكون امرأة محترفة
طبيب محامي جميع أنواع
المهن المختلفة التي كانت
تنشر هذا ولكن تمضي وقتًا
جيدًا وشاهدته للجمهور وبالطبع
هذا يذهب إلى قلب ما
نتحدث عنه هنا امرأة على
رأس حكومة كانت
تعتبر أنها حققت أداءً جيدًا بشكل ملحوظ من
خلال رعاية فنلندا من
خلال الخروج من نهجها الحيادي ،
فقد حصلت على 800 ميل من الحدود مع
روسيا نحو عضوية الناتو
امرأة كانت عندما تولت السلطة في سن الرابعة والثلاثين في عام
2019 ، كانت أصغر رئيسة وزراء
في العالم حتى في ذلك الوقت ، برزت في
صور العائلة ، حيث تم إبداء الكثير من النظرات
ومرة ​​أخرى تتعرض لانتقادات بسبب
تلك الصورة ، السؤال الذي تقوله النساء
هو أنها كذلك  أن
ألتزم بمعايير أعلى بالنظر إلى أنه لم
يتم فعل أي شيء غير قانوني أكثر من عمر أي رجل على الإطلاق
ولن أرقص